and finally new rule americans need to
re-watch ken burns great documentary on
prohibition because people are starting
to notice
america has a drinking problem
now i can't believe that we would be
ever so stupid as to outlaw booze again
but that doesn't mean we shouldn't take
notice when the nation goes through one
of its periodic
binge drinking phases like we are in now
since the turn of the millennium alcohol
consumption in this country has risen
steadily and
alcohol-related deaths have doubled even
millennials who used to be the more
sober generation are now dying of
cirrhosis of the liver at record rates
and that was before covet hit when
locked down nation really hit the bottle
the pandemic was an excuse for people to
drink more
drink in the day and drink alone a
condition
psychologists call melania
we lost all sense of time and the rules
went out the window
restaurants were delivering cocktails
with hard liquor
i know this because they were delivering
them to my house
because as long as i had liquor i didn't
care there was no toilet paper
but just as a historical trend this
can't be good there is a word
for when everyone in society gets drunk
just to get through the day
and that word is russia
and i do mean through the day because
even before gopher we started putting
liquor everywhere
every month you could see some viral
video of an all out brawl
at chuck e cheese because even this
children's restaurant serves beer now
united southwest and american airlines
have all either cut back or stopped
serving alcohol
because there have been so many recent
incidents where the passengers
act like mel gibson at a traffic stop
[Applause]
the flight crew has to treat us like
children now i will turn this plane
around and no one will go to dallas fort
worth
grocery stores now serve beer on tap
the first time ever husbands are asking
honey you need me to pick up anything at
the market
[Applause]
supermarkets also invite customers to
shop and sip
from their open wine bars belly up mom
leave your troubles in the produce
department
and your baby in the car
you'll get over it but hey
if you get drunk at whole foods please
remember
vomit in a reusable bag
movie theaters now also serve beer and
wine and sometimes hard liquor so does
taco bell
and disneyland and starbucks you thought
they had trouble spelling your name on
the cup before
and of course what's the point of living
large if you can't get offered a drink
when you
shop and get your hair done
book clubs have long been just an excuse
to guzzle wine the way
fishing is really just drinking on a
boat and
hunting is drinking in the woods and
bowling is drinking with rented shoes on
you know
aquariums serve alcohol now and
zoos zoos who gets shit-faced at the zoo
when did people start saying you know if
i'm gonna stare at a polar bear taking a
nap i'm gonna need a couple of stiff
ones i
alcohol is everywhere on tv now hosts of
the today show have it on their desk
i've seen guests on watch what happens
live have it in their hands
and of course stars of the real
housewives have it on their faces
[Music]
now maybe you recognize yourself in some
of this
ask you
[Laughter]
ask yourself do i drink in the morning
do i drink alone do i receive mystery
packages from amazon that make me ask
when did i order snowshoes
this is all eerily familiar in the
prohibition documentary the first
episode is called a nation of drunkards
and it describes how on farms in the
19th century there was a
barrel of hard cider by the door which
you dipped into every time you came and
went
ken burns writes americans routinely
drank at every meal
including breakfast in many towns a bell
rang twice a day to signal what was
called grog
time so that men could stop whatever
they were doing in factories and offices
mills and farm fields and drink
well here in the now times we seem to be
heading back in that direction
and i think the reason is this the covet
epidemic
may be subsiding but the epidemic that
preceded it
the anxiety epidemic is not
and usually when people drink it's to
alleviate some form of anxiety
as we re-enter society half of americans
say covet has been so stressful they
worry they'll never fully recover
we're using liquor as a crutch for our
pandemic exacerbated problem of being
socially impaired
we call it social media but really it's
the opposite of social
and our increasing detachment from one
another in real life and
dependence on screens and online
relationships
makes us ever more vulnerable to the
allure of liquid courage
when it comes to really interacting with
people
but drinking my friends is not the
answer
okay it's part of the answer i'm not
going to lie it's part of you
yes take taking
taking the edge off a bit yes i myself
have a long history of using liquor to
take the edge off
usually off some other drug but still
but not at two in the afternoon not at
the piggly wiggly
and definitely not at the zoo we have
got to get a handle on
our anxiety and it can't be through the
bottle everybody needs to just get a
grip
now if you'll excuse me my my vacation
just started and there's a cool one
waiting for me in the dressing room
you